kampf gegen die krone ausbreitung
etliche bundesländer untersagen
veranstaltungen mit mehr als 1000
teilnehmern österreich greift zu noch
schärferen maßnahmen und italien
reduziert das öffentliche leben auf ein
minimum weiter an der macht durch eine
verfassungsreform könnte präsident putin
noch jahrelang an russlands spitze
stehen und beethoven schwarz auf weiß
zum 250 geburtstag ist in berlin im
original zu sehen was das genie
hinterlassen hat
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem dienstag sport gibt es auch in
der sendung norbert lehmann schon gut
familie der kampf gegen das corona virus
hemd zunehmend das öffentliche leben im
besonders betroffenen italien sowieso da
gilt inzwischen für alle 60 millionen
einwohner nur mit triftigem grund darf
man haus oder wohnung verlassen
in deutschland verbieten immer mehr
bundesländer großveranstaltungen immer
mehr fußball spiele finden ohne publikum
statt und österreichs regierung geht
noch weiter
dort sind veranstaltungen drinnen mit
mehr als 100 teilnehmern verboten auch
universitäten und fachhochschulen
bleiben geschlossen unterrichtet wird
per internet im freien gilt das verbot
ab einer größe von 500 personen
drastisch sind die maßnahmen an der
grenze zu italien nach österreich rein
darf nur noch wer gesund oder auf der
durchreise ist wolf christian ullrich
berichtet
österreich macht ernst am brenner
offiziell ein reiseverbot für italiener
und grenzkontrolle mit fieber messen in
abhängigkeit ob man eine erhöhte
temperatur beziehungsweise die ballette
würde man weitere untersuchungen
vornehmen
touristen dürfen von italien nach
deutschland fahren doch sie dürfen nicht
in österreich halt machen ab jetzt soll
kontrolliert werden ob der tank voll ist
hier ist das oberste ziel die
verhinderung des austausches und somit
das einschleppen der erkrankung in
unsere gesellschaft
in weiterer folge wird es keine flüge
umzüge mehr aus italien nach österreich
geben
die regierung verkündet weitere
einschränkungen arbeitnehmer sollen wenn
möglich von zu hause aus arbeiten
die fußball liga pausiert innen
veranstaltungen von sport und kultur ab
100 gästen abgesagt selbst der
stephansdom gesperrt das trifft auch die
universitäten hier in innsbruck sind die
hörsäle schon leer
die uni wien schließt morgen für vier
wochen
wir stellen ab morgen auf home learning
um da ist ein wesentlicher teil in
learning aber es war nach alten reformen
darunter wie selbststudium und ähnliches
die österreicher sehen die maßnahmen
unterschiedlich
also ich glaube schon dass es ein wenig
mit panikmache ist ehrlich gesagt für
mich ist es ein bisschen zu spät ich
finde das hätten schon viel früher
machen müssen und ich hoffe dass sie in
deutschland besitzt auch bald machen
werden nicht nur ein brenner österreich
versucht sich vor dem virus zu schützen
und wir fragen nach an der
österreichisch-italienischen grenze am
brenner und in rom zunächst zu patricia
schäfer wie läuft die abschottung nach
italien ja barbara abschottung und ein
reisestopp das klingt sehr strengen aber
wie sie sehen
läuft der grenzverkehr hinter mir ganz
normale sind in den letzten minuten
allein dutzende lkw aus italien
auch aus anderen europäischen ländern
aus italien kommend hier durchgefahren
die landespolizei tirol sagt ja die
grenzen sind noch offen denn man brauche
zeit für die vorbereitung das soll in
den nächsten tagen erst greifen
dieses von der regierung von der
österreichischen regierung verkündete
der einreise stopp und zwar muster vom
innenministerium noch eine verordnung
ausgearbeitet werden es müssen noch
poller aufgestellt werden und so lange
wird auch morgen dann wieder nur
sporadisch kontrolliert wie für heute
den ganzen tag über sind etwa 100
personen kontrolliert worden alle 20
minuten mal
es wurde bei niemandem wurden symptome
festgestellt niemand wurde an der
einreise nach österreich gehindert in
italien selbst herrschen ja im ganzen
land reise und versammlungen andreas
postel aber arbeiten und einkaufen gehen
dürfen die menschen hier tut die casa
titelte heute eine große italienische
tageszeitung alle bleiben zuhause
anfänglich gab es etwas konfusion wie
weitreichend denn und die konsequenzen
hier sind und die regelungen die
getroffen wurden aber die italiener sind
heute morgen aller meistens zur arbeit
gefahren auch mit öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln sie haben sich darum
gekümmert dass die kinder die nicht zur
schule gehen können betreut werden und
die geschäfte haben auch so dass man
sich auch mit den waren des täglichen
bedarfs eindecken kann es geht in erster
linie darum die ausbreitung des
ohne virus in italien weiter zur
verfügung und der risikopatienten zu
schützen
denn das durchschnittsalter der
verstorbenen hier liegt bei 81 jahren
und die meisten hatten sehr schwere
vorerkrankungen dankeschön für diese
information aus ruhm und aus tirol
in deutschland ist die gefahr für die
bevölkerung bisher mäßig sagt das
robert-koch-institut sie variieren aber
von region zu region am meisten
infizierten gibt es noch immer in
nordrhein-westfalen im kreis heinsberg
gefolgt von bayern
dort sind mittlerweile 87 schulen
geschlossen großveranstaltungen seit
heute verboten aus münchen claudia vor
ihm und draußen die tränen gähnende
leere in bayern mussten bereits mehrere
tausend schüler zu hause bleiben erst
gut eine woche nach den faschingsferien
zieht das kultusministerium die
notbremse sobald ein kind infiziert ist
für die gesamte schule geschlossen
auch an rupprecht gymnasium in münchen
fällt der unterricht aus hier sorgt sich
der schulleiter um die abiturienten der
q12 ende april stehen die
abschlussprüfungen an
insbesondere unsere q12 würde viel
lieber in den unterricht gekommen
denn wir können klar dass nicht voll
ersetzen noch ist unklar ob die
abiturprüfungen verschoben werden müssen
man kann hier nichts bestätigen die
einrichtung in richtung auch nichts
ausschließen also insofern wert wird tag
für tag schauen wie sich die zahlen
entwickeln jeweils auch das risiko
bewerten unsicherheit auch bei den
bayerischen abiturienten auch am
münchner luise gymnasium noch hoffen sie
dass der termin nicht verschoben wird
ich will es hinter mich bringen ich
hoffe jetzt einfach mal dass es nicht
passiert ich fänds bisschen schade weil
auch viele sich schon so weiter
vorbereitet hatten und auch viele schon
reisen geplant hätten viele
fußballspiele werden ohne zuschauer
stattfinden auch in bayern bis zum 19
april werden veranstaltungen mit mehr
als 1000 besuchern abgesagt wir sagen
die veranstaltung ab die notwendig sind
aus unserer sicht und empfehlen auch
selbst noch mal zu überlegen muss er
bestimmte veranstaltung machen oder
nicht auch theateraufführungen und
konzerte staatlicher einrichtungen
werden im freistaat vorerst gestrichen
das corona virus hat auch bayern fest im
griff
die große koalition will bis zu einer
milliarde euro im kampf gegen das corona
virus zur verfügung stellen außerdem hat
sie im eiltempo wirtschaftshilfen für
unternehmen beschlossen
auch die eu wird aktiv damit die staaten
im kampf gegen das virus besser
zusammenarbeiten
stefan lobenstein auch die eu hat sich
wegen corona umgestellt video konferenz
der staats und regierungschefs mit
ratspräsident michelle am abend ziel ein
gemeinsames vorgehen zu finden
in deutschland geht es jetzt darum die
wirtschaft zu stützen
die bundesregierung hat dazu im
eilverfahren veränderung bei der
kurzarbeit beschlossen
künftig müssen nur noch zehn prozent der
belegschaft von arbeitsausfall betroffen
sein
auch leiharbeiter erhalten
kurzarbeitergeld arbeitgeber müssen für
kurzarbeiter keine sozialabgaben mehr
zahlen die bundesagentur für arbeit
springt ein mit rücklagen von 26
milliarden euro
ab anfang april soll die änderung in
kraft treten
auch für neue überbrückungskredite gibt
es gespräche in der regierung
im übrigen bin ich mit dem kollegen
urlaub stolz dabei diese regelungen zu
evaluieren und gegebenenfalls auch die
dafür zur verfügung stehenden
finanziellen mittel aufzustocken
aktuell schätzt das rk ii die
ansteckungsgefahr als mehr sich ein
jedoch gibt es regionale hotspots und es
gibt noch viel zu tun
ich fordere alle bürgermeister und
landräte auf ihre krisenpläne zu
aktivieren die krankenhäuser müssen sich
darauf vorbereiten wenn sie mehr schwer
schwere fälle haben dass sie die
entsprechenden strukturen in ihren
krankenhäusern anpassen
damit meint er mehr intensivbetten und
absagen verschiebbare operationen in
china dem vom corona virus am härtesten
betroffenen land geht nach offiziellen
angaben die zahl der neuinfektionen
weiter zurück von den mehr als 80.000
infizierten haben rund 60.000 die
krankenhäuser wieder verlassen
erstmals seit ausbruch des virus ist
präsident china angereist und versucht
zu beruhigen
die epidemie sei unter kontrolle ingo
hahn war das neu
einige virus zuerst aufgetreten und wenn
sie noch mehr informationsbedarf haben
alle entwicklungen rund um das coruna
virus gibt es zum nachlesen jederzeit
auch online auf heute de finden sie
unseren live blog mit den neuesten
entwicklungen und aktuellen zahlen neue
verfassung neuer präsident nein auf
diese kurzformel lässt sich der
beschluss des russischen parlaments
heute bringen
eigentlich müsste präsident punkten
nämlich spätestens 2024 abtreten dann
hätte er die höchstzahl von zwei
amtszeiten hintereinander erreicht doch
mit der neuen verfassung soll die
rechnung wieder bei null beginnen die
ära putin könnte also noch sehr lange
weitergehen aus moskau für begann einst
war sie die erste frau im weltall
heute ist sie die erste abgeordnete die
im parlament offen ausspricht worüber in
russland schon lange gemunkelt wird
ich schlage vor dass wir einen artikel
aufnehmen der es dem amtierenden
präsidenten erlaubt sobald die neue
verfassung in kraft ist wie jeder andere
bürger des landes für die
präsidentschaft zu kandidieren
die duma nimmt ihren vorschlag an
sie ebnet somit den weg für eine
verfassung die möglich macht was bisher
ausgeschlossen schien wladimir putin
könnte über das jahr 2024 hinaus im amt
bleiben
es geht um die stärkung einer
autoritären ordnung die sich in den
letzten jahren herausgebildet hat solche
umbauten an der verfassung sind für
andere postsowjetischen staaten
charakteristisch besonders für die
staaten zentralasiens wo sich der
autoritäre muss bereits etabliert hat am
nachmittag tauchte präsident putin in
der duma auf er begrüßt die möglichkeit
länger im amt zu bleiben
wenig überraschend wie überhaupt vieles
durch orchestriert wird am heutigen tag
russlands außerparlamentarische
opposition schäumt und kündigt proteste
an
es ist eine schande die gesamte
rechtsordnung wird umgekrempelt wenn sie
sich jetzt die regeln für ihre eigene
amtszeiten selbst ändern
ich kann nur noch nervös lachen in
seiner rede betonte präsident putin noch
wie wichtig ein
wechsel für russland sein doch das
scheint erst für die zeit nach ihm zu
gelten
zurück nach deutschland hier nimmt die
aggressivität gegen kommunalpolitiker
offenbar weiter zu 64 prozent der
bürgermeister sind laut einer umfrage
schon einmal beleidigt oder bedroht
worden
neun prozent gaben spuckt oder
geschlagen in zwickau haben heute
betroffene dem bundespräsidenten von
ihren erfahrungen berichtet franziska
wunderlich sozialen netzwerken auch im
amt romina bad ist oberbürgermeisterin
im sächsischen torgau mit 36 jahren eine
der jüngsten in deutschland doch auch
sie wird schnell zur zielscheibe vor
allem frauenfeindlicher hass postings es
ist natürlich so dass man schon die eine
oder andere nacht vielleicht etwas
unruhe über schläft oder wenn man nachts
das rathaus verlässt so später stunde
dass man anders darüber nachdenkt und
ich bin zum beispiel persönlich noch zu
einem selbstverteidigungskurs gegangen
sie erstattet anzeige
aber das verfahren wird eingestellt wie
ihr geht es vielen kommunalpolitikern
heute trafen sie sich um darüber zu
diskutieren
mit bürgern experten und auch mit dem
bundespräsidenten aber jüngst haben die
übergriffe ein ausmass eine häufigkeit
erreicht die mir eben in der tat nur
eine schlussfolgerung erlauben wir
dürfen nicht zulassen dass
kommunalpolitikerinnen und politiker in
unserem land zu fußabtreter der
frustrierten würden neben
gesellschaftlicher verantwortung sei
auch die bundespolitik gefragt ein
gesetzentwurf sieht vor
kommunalpolitiker besser zu schützen und
digitale hetze schärfer zu ahnden
gerade mit sohn auf veranstaltungen wie
heute hat man deutlich gezeigt dass man
das verstanden hat dass man es gehört
hat und dass man in diesem bereich
deutlich mehr tun muss und der
gesetzentwurf ist schon der richtige
schritt in die richtung nach hause fahre
sie mit dem gefühl ernst genommen und in
ihrer arbeit wertgeschätzt zu werden
er war ein genie ein gigant der
klassischen musik und ein leidender der
taub wurde ludwig van beethoven dass
hier etwa hörte er selbst nie
[Musik]
die original notenblätter der berühmten
9 und weitere schriften und briefe
beethoven sind nun in berlin zu sehen
all das seine persönliche handschrift
sozusagen nun zu bestaunen zu seinem 250
geburtstag stefan haase bürger
[Musik]
gerade bei der fünften sinfonie hat er
ein motiv verwendet das ganz kurz ist
und aus diesem ganz kurzen motiv vater
praktisch die ganze sinfonie gebaut und
es ist wirklich ganz einzigartig
einfach eingängig kraftvoll mitreißend
beethovens fünfte ein revolutionäres
werk
die staatsbibliothek unter den linden in
berlin zeigt in ihrer beethoven
ausstellung das original der partitur
das haus besitzt wahre schätze die hoch
empfindlich sind und sonst tief in
tresoren lagern porträts des großen
komponisten konversation hefte und
briefe darunter seinen persönlichsten
den an die unsterbliche geliebte mein
engel man alles mein ich so beginnt
beethoven ihn heirat das große glück
blieb ihm verwehrt doch wer war die
angebetete vielleicht die adlige
josephine brunswick genau weiß man es
nicht
er hat sich hinter falschen frauen
verliebt es waren stets frauen die
eigentlich unerreichbar waren indem sie
einfach nicht seinem stand entsprachen
prunkstück ist die originalpartitur der
neunten sinfonie mit der weltberühmten
ode an die freude die verheißung einer
besseren welt
[Musik]
immer wieder so schön und wir müssen
jetzt trotzdem noch mal zum corona ja
dann kommst du übrigens noch mal zum
gruner virus leute haben da spielt eine
große rolle her muss bei der bundesliga
zwei spiele zwei derbys die abgesagt
worden sind nämlich gladbach gegen köln
morgen und dortmund gegen schalke am
samstag mindestens fünf weitere partien
am wochenende die werden auch vor leeren
rängen stattfinden aber in leipzig wird
zumindest heute abend noch vor vollem
haus gespielt in der champions league
die leipzig steigt die spannung um nicht
zu sagen das fußballfieber nach dem 1 0
sieg im hinspiel gegen tottenham wollen
r&b und seine fans ins viertelfinale
angst vor dem virus gibt es hier nicht
also ich mach das was ich noch machen
ich treffe meine freunde in gladbach
morgen das erste spiel der bundesliga
geschichte vor leeren tribünen
ein entsprechender erlass der
landesregierung untersagt bis auf
weiteres alle großveranstaltungen mit
mehr als 1000 zuschauern in
nordrhein-westfalen ich glaube das ist
vor allem darum geht dass wir uns in so
einer situation mit den leuten
solidarisieren die tatsächlich schaden
davontragen können führt heute ältere
personen und kleine kinder
wie viele weitere bundesländer stopp
bayern vorerst alle großveranstaltungen
damit wird auch das länderspiel ende
märz gegen italien ein geisterspiel eine
einheitliche lösung fehlanzeige union
fans mit ticket dürfen sich weiter auf
das bundesligaspiel am samstag im
stadion gegen die bayern freuen
berlins behörden gaben grünes licht für
die begegnung ja und in der deutschen
eishockey liga wurden soeben alle
playoff spiele abgesagt das heißt die
saison ist beendet einen deutschen
meister gibt es nicht heiko herrlich
soll fußball bundesligist fc augsburg
vor dem absturz in die zweitklassigkeit
bewahren
der 48 jährige hält als nachfolger des
gestern entlassenen martin schmid einen
vertrag bis 2022 zur tournee der
skispringer in norwegen heute der zweite
einzel wettbewerb der männer in
lillehammer ja und den hut vor wenigen
minuten kamen stoch gewonnen der pole
sprangen im zweiten durchgang auf 100 0
30 metern der weiteste sprung des tages
bester deutscher stephan leyhe auf rang
neun in der tourwertung bleibt lange
zweiter mit hauchdünnem rückstand von
mit von 0,7 punkte auf den führenden
stock ja und das frauen skispringen
da haben wir das gibt's nur unter 20 uhr
zu sehen im livestream in der zdf
mediathek kindern kann
ungleich ist der regen morgen verteilt
wo die sonne scheint sagt ihm gleich ist
intern im heute journal um viertel vor
zehn spricht claus kleber mit
arbeitsminister heil über die
auswirkungen des corona virus hier ist
morgen wieder christian sievers dran ich
danke für ihr interesse und wünsche
ihnen noch einen möglichst unbeschwerten
abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein chocolat amt und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter nass wird es über der mitte
deutschlands denn hier ziehen so einige
fronten durch erst einmal eine kaltfront
mit viel regen dann eine warmfront und
danach folgt wieder eine kaltfront sehen
nach norden hier fließt kühlere luft ein
und im süden eher wärmere luft in der
nacht gibt es viele wolken und regen und
dieser regen verlagert sich in die mitte
kann auch ergiebig und andauernd seien
dazu gibt es stürmische böen aus west
ganz im norden lockert es schon mal auf
und ganz im süden ist es ebenfalls
trocken temperaturen sinken dabei auf 4
grad im südosten deutschlands und 12
grad im westen
morgen dann viele wolken über der mitte
es regnet ebenfalls länger andauernd und
teils ergiebig davon merken sie im
norden kaum etwas da scheint längere
zeit die sonne
und auch im südwesten zeigt sich die
sonne immer wieder der wind ist
allerdings kräftig aus südwestlichen
richtungen temperaturen erreichen
höchstwerte von 15 bis 17 grad im süden
hier also die wärmere luftmassen
deutlich kühler an der küste mit zehn
bis zwölf grad die nächsten tagen am
donnerstag wird zwar bis 18 grad mild es
gibt aber noch schauer die abziehen
kräftiger wind aus südwesten und die
darauf folgenden tage sind deutlich
kühler
ein schöner abend